lo que quiero hacer a continuación es
una serie de problemas que nos permitan
asegurar que sabemos cuando trabajamos
con líneas paralelas y triángulos y otro
tipo de conceptos lo que tenemos aquí es
un problema clásico ahora lo que quiero
hacer es que lo resolvamos con la
información que disponemos obviamente
tengo un triángulo aquí y otro triángulo
acá y nos han dado algunos de los
ángulos internos de estos triángulos a
partir de dicha información hay que
resolver cuál es la medida de este
ángulo justo aquí quiero saber que hay
en la interrogación así que podrías
intentarlo antes de que yo lo resuelva
deberás recordar algunos resultados como
que la suma de las medidas de los
ángulos internos de un triángulo es 180
grados y tal vez un poco de lo que ya
sabe sobre ángulos suplementarios podrás
hacerlo tú mismo inténtalo
lo primero que deberemos decir y esto es
una manera muy general de pensar en
estos problemas que te dan algunos
ángulos debe resolver algunos otros
basándote en que la suma de los ángulos
internos de un triángulo son 180 y bueno
en este caso no tenemos líneas para
pero si tenemos algunos ángulos
suplementarios debemos imaginar un
camino u otro que nos permitan resolver
qué hay en esta interrogación lo primero
que me viene a la mente es que tenemos
un triángulo justo aquí este y tenemos
este triángulo a la izquierda y sobre
este nos han dado dos ángulos si tienes
dos de los ángulos de un triángulo
siempre puedes resolver el tercer ángulo
ya que suman 180 grados
llamémoslo x sabemos que x más 50 más 64
grados será igual a 180 o podríamos
decir x más 114 que es la suma de estos
dos ángulos es igual a 180 restamos 114
de ambos lados entonces tenemos x es
igual a 180 menos 114 180 menos 100 son
80 luego 80 menos 10 son 70 y menos 4
son 66
así que x es 66 grados ahora vamos a
encontrar otro ángulo que no sea tan
difícil de resolver
déjenme escribirlo de esta forma como x
es igual a 1 mejor mejor de este lado x
es igual a 66 grados bueno si nosotros
conocemos este ángulo de aquí si sabemos
que la medida del ángulo de 66 grados
entonces el ángulo suplementario que es
esté pintado en magenta ambos el magenta
y x deben formar un ángulo de 180 grados
llamemos a este ángulo y por lo tanto ye
más x debe ser 180
sabiendo que x vale 66 grados aquí este
es 66 grados extremos 66 de ambos lados
de la ecuación
entonces nos queda igual a 180 menos 66
que son 114 y este número debe ser
familiar para ti observa que es el mismo
que la suma de los otros dos ángulos
internos de este triángulo en realidad
es una idea general que mostraré en este
momento digamos que tengo estos dos
ángulos que la medida de este es a la
medida de esteve y la medida de éste
pues ya sabemos que 180 menos a menos b
este ángulo es considerado un ángulo
exterior en nuestro ejemplo original el
que es el ángulo exterior al ángulo x en
este ejemplo es nuestro ángulo exterior
suplementario a 180 menos a menos b por
lo que este ángulo más 180 menos a menos
b debe ser igual a 180 si lo llamamos
debes satisfacer que gemma 108
también nos ve es igual a 180 restamos
180 de ambos lados se cancela sumamos a
ive de ambos lados de la ecuación
sumamos a y b
sumamos a ive y estos dos se cancelan se
cancelan las hadas se cancelan las veces
del lado izquierdo y nos queda igual a b
esto es una propiedad general puedes
hacer un razonamiento como el que
hicimos de este lado donde la suma de
los ángulos internos de un triángulo son
180 y luego queremos encontrar el ángulo
exterior a equis o bien utilizamos esta
propiedad tenemos los ángulos exteriores
por aquí y estos son iguales a la suma
de los ángulos remotos sólo estamos
agregando un poco de terminología al
problema de cualquier manera y es igual
a más b que son los ángulos remotos en
este caso ya sabíamos que eran 50 más 64
que son los 114 grados o bien podríamos
conocerlo si ya conocíamos de antemano
esta propiedad sobre los ángulos
exteriores
de cualquier forma llevarles 114 grados
y conocemos desde el inicio este ángulo
que vale 31 grados ahora podemos
encontrar el valor del signo de
interrogación vamos a llamarle
a este ángulo entonces sabemos que z
cumple que z114 más 31 debe ser igual a
180 grados otra vez la suma de los
ángulos internos de un triángulo suman
180 grados es la única propiedad que
estamos utilizando en este paso así
obtenemos z más lo que resulta de esta
suma que son 145 son 180 sólo déjenme
revisar un poco las cuentas tengo un 15
y un 30 claro 145 restamos 145 de ambos
lados de la ecuación y resulta de este
lado que z es igual a
35 grados y listo
concluimos el ejercicio